Changing weather patterns around the world are
having a massive effect
on the lives of vulnerable communities.
Historic monsoon rains are flooding South Asia,
East Africa is reeling from drought
and the Caribbean is being buffeted
by violent hurricane
after violent hurricane.
And indigenous people, who ironically
contribute the least
to greenhouse gas emissions,
are suffering the most.
It’s estimated that 24% of the land on earth
is occupied by 370 million
indigenous people.
And these territories contain 80%
of the world’s biodiversity.
Off the coast of Panama, we discovered an
indigenous island community
that's already losing its home to the rising sea.
And it's not just their ancestral land that's at risk,
but also their traditional ways of life.
But one island isn't going down without a fight,
and has come up with a plan
to save their community.
Gardi Sugdup is one of the 365 islands
that make up the Guna Yala archipelago.
The Guna tribe has controlled the region
for the past 200 years.
Today, more than 50,000 indigenous
Gunas inhabit the islands.
But now they're being forced
to uproot their lives
and move to “La Barriada” – 42 acres
of Panamanian jungle
that they’ve set aside for a new community.
In the last 30 years, the sea levels
around the islands
have risen over 2.4 millimeters. It may
not seem like much,
but it has led to over 50,000
square feet of land loss.
And as the island shrinks away,
the population booms.
Over 1,000 people live on an
area of only .3 square miles.
For years, the islanders mined coral reef
and used it to try to extend their island.
But that only made matters worse.
Now, the community sees a
move back to the mainland
as the only viable option.
But moving has been complicated.
The Guna already owned the land
for their relocation,
but clearing the thick jungle
and building proper infrastructure is costly.
In 2010, they received funds from the government
to build a new school and hospital,
but progress has been slow.
There are also mixed feelings
about moving the community.
Some fear it could mean a
loss of independence.
On the islands, the Guna have been
able to preserve their traditions,
like making these colorful dresses
called molas.
By 2050, an estimated 50 to 200
million people could be displaced
due to climate change.
Gardi Sugdup is hoping to serve not only
as a model for their own community,
but also for other island communities
around the world.